hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba look
who's back in tactic at the Alvarado
she's here with a red lipstick on look
how red really brings out the pallor you
can fall cat on Instagram cat Alvarado
comp no what is it it's a cat the cat I
know I'm sorry I remember every other
detail about your life except your
social media handle which is a good side
of our friendship hey cat is funny but
this cat have a hard time not laughing
tune in next week challenge
bonniest guy i've seen two of them so
far these are going around the internet
like crazy these try not to laugh
challenge for Family Guy apparently it's
really hard not to laugh at Family Guy
yeah it's a funny show so by definition
roles rules of the game okay obviously
don't laugh you can't smile you can't go
like boom laughing smiling and if you
happen to laugh just start again don't
go
I already laughed screw it I'm just
gonna keep on laughing that's not fun
alright we're not recording too by the
way
[Laughter]
well supporting is real
yeah okay into the eternal pit of fire
you go
[Music]
is there any way you can describe that
to me using colorful puppets of some
sort that box won't bother to us just
some idiot streaking across the field
you are all working at mightiness you
didn't plan on it but it's happening I'm
scared of ghosts there's no such thing
as ghosts are you sure it's safe under
here right I think so but I'm not sure I
just recently started believing it go
remember 2008 yes I was for many now
that Louis has connections at Fox we are
going to invent our own fat tone show
and we are here to brainstorm ideas all
right don't anything a pop city ahead
ooh how about a bunch of disabled Ducks
it will call it handi-quacks Wow caught
fire a little earlier than I thought we
would perfect
all right let's spend many hours on this
all right the main duck what's his name
I don't know red hiney monkey all right
now what's this wacky baby ducks name
dee dee goose Maggie please try to
formulate ideas clearly before you
vocalize them I'm not sure you're
getting the show man all right names
names names come on goofy face your
video knows yes write it down hurry
hurry maybe they live in a pot of course
can I talk to you in the kitchen first
this is too real this is like my
experience in comedy I don't think
people need breakfast anyone more
suggestions ooh where's red hiney monkey
and poopyface tomato nose are trying to
build a house of cards falling down all
right let's take a walk down this road
see where it leads us dialogue what are
they saying
um Mimi poopyface tomato nose says boy
this house of cards just doesn't want to
stay up well yeah if you want to go
right at it like a Neanderthal sure but
I think we're shooting for a little more
subtlety yeah you know I don't believe
that I don't believe that that's a real
conversation when I hear it people don't
talk like that I'm here because we just
bought that here wood stove Chris we
have work done I'm sorry I'm so sorry
but none of this stuff seems to make
sense I mean we haven't even referenced
the fact that they're ducks or that
they're handicapped but the show is
called handi-quacks crush can I see you
in the kitchen
now see the joke is most people only
carry a suitcase when they don't want to
show he's whole bit but hook we face the
metronomes carries one all the time
let's see he's got a sleeve hanging out
right oh well you know what could be
funny
maybe one week he actually goes on
vacation and he's already got the
suitcase question I see you in the
kitchen first rule of three maybe your
services will no longer be needed keep
it safe now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god who the hell cares
Peter I'm telling you guys it's gonna be
a disaster just like the future
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well [ __ ] you thank you for meeting me
here I have something very important to
tell you I have something important to
tell you too Peter I think we should see
other people
okay it ended but that's a Brooks I know
how do you do that sometimes Wow can we
just say that writers bit most of the
try not to laugh dedicated to this this
is what bit one of the things I find so
funny about their show is what their
cartoon characters so when they have
real life conversations it's really
funny some reason it's just an isolated
moment of just putting them back to back
it was like this is a little dark and
heavy for my los angeles mind right now
that's a female right I can imagine oh
god it just felt like my nightmare
scenario of like that's exactly what
would happen like oh my god have you
been in a scenario scenario or scenario
your [ __ ] [ __ ] citizen scenario
like that fortunately no cuz I'm funny
we'll see about that cat I'm gonna call
everyone I know in Hollywood make sure
no one hires your comedy was that my is
that a good old time I wasn't sure what
you were doing voice you know she does
like old timey things
ah well never met a hard
that's good that was better that was
good I don't know what Mae West sounds
like neither do I at they were saying
mayor west which is character family you
watch I do know that it seems like such
a universal show I never talked with
anyone about Family Guy cuz we've been
watching it for like ten years or longer
than that at this point so it's like not
a thing we talked about like no one
talks about the Simpsons either
well no one watches The Simpsons anymore
do you know no one watches The Simpsons
I think Fox is just like I don't know
anyone who still watches The Simpsons
sure enough we're gonna get a bunch of
comments of people going oh hey
I still watch The Simpsons good for you
singular viewer did you ever have like
teachers show you episodes of The
Simpsons in school I had that in high
school they would play like oh and this
historical topic was talked to like
there was one night of the rape it's
some kind of Edgar Allan Poe in that
they would always show no I mean I go I
was in Catholic school in elementary
junior high and they were very much anti
Simpsons I mean I said yes I went to the
heathenistic public schools of
California where they showed this I
think my favorite one was the one where
it's the hey there Delila and the
changing shirts and then the demon comes
in the back ya know with a grudge one
[Laughter]
you could just feel that there are
people who are high in the writers room
just throwing because that's the one
thing with the family guys you can't
just go we're gonna be funny if this act
like Family Guy is the one show where
you can't imagine that with the writers
room because they have these cutaway
bits yeah so you can just before you
deserve it okay like we just have a
punch bowl of ideas you can do that one
is like saying scenarios and one is
random ask crazy things and they just
pick up them and then they like put that
on the board and then they have
diagram with all the board stuff and
then and then they write it just like
Suzy it's your job and then they have
had free write up for Suzy the Suzy's no
good but they're not gonna fire her
because they don't wanna get sued
I just read an entire backstory for this
entire bit which is that like they gave
Suzy the job to like write this script
so she wrote it and she's like yeah I
heard everything you guys said and I put
it in the script now and they're like
nah and so they had to like put it in
I'm gonna be crazy that that happened
Chris guy talk to you for a sec guys
thanks for tuning in you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification about follow Kat Alvarado
on Instagram she does not tweet I don't
know why you don't have you been
tweeting tweeting because I feel like
you'd be a great Twitter and yeah thank
you guys